aferrados a la esperanza de encontrar
sobrevivientes
habitantes del estado de sao paulo se
unen a los bomberos en un intento por
hallar a sus seres queridos trabajan
para remover las viviendas sepultadas
por los derrumbes no sobre o busco mi
sobrino su esposa y su hijo de dos años
no dijeron que los cuerpos siguen ahí
debajo del lodo pero hasta ahora no han
podido recuperarlos las inundaciones y
deslizamientos de tierra causados por
las fuertes lluvias en el sureste de
brasil arrasaron con barrios enteros a
su paso
ayer escuché un sonido cuando fui al
baño y después corrí y
cuando empecé a correr me cayeron
escombros por todas partes
con tropas y lastimé pero encontré un
hueco y gracias a dios logré escapar
pero mi padre sigue ahí a su tejado
desde octubre pasado las fuertes lluvias
han provocado inundaciones mortales en
este país primero en el sureste en donde
retrasaron cosechas y forzaron por
momentos la suspensión de operaciones
mineras en el estado de minas gerais
después en el noreste en el de bahía y
ahora el temporal vuelve al sureste esa
vez a sao paulo las lluvias fueron muy
fuertes la concentración de lluvia fue
mucho más fuerte de lo que estamos
acostumbrados
después de sobrevolar el domingo las
zonas inundadas el gobernador de sao
paulo joao doria prometió una partida de
43 millones de dólares para ayudar a los
27 municipios afectados